Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A decision tree is a great tool to help making
good decisions from a huge bunch of data.
The classical example is when we have a bunch
of information about people and would like
to find out whether they like computer games
or not. Note that this is a toy example for
educational purposes.
We can build the following tree: if the person's
age in question is over 15, the person is
less likely to like computer games. If the
subject is under 15 and is a male, he is quite
likely to like video games, if she's female,
then less likely.
Note that the output of the tree can be a
decision, like yes or no, but in our case,
we will assign positive and negative scores
instead. You'll see in a minute why that's beneficial.
But this tree wa s just one possible way of
approaching the problem, and admittedly, not
a spectacular one - a different decision tree
could be simply asking whether this person
uses a computer daily or not.
Individually, these trees are quite shallow
and we call them weak learners. This term
means that individually, they are quite inaccurate,
but slightly better than random guessing.
And now comes the cool part. The concept of
tree boosting means that we take many weak
learners and combine them into a strong learner.
Using the mentioned scoring system instead
of decisions also makes this process easy
and straightforward to implement.
Boosting is similar to what we do with illnesses.
If a doctor says that I have a rare condition,
I will make sure and ask at least a few more
doctors to make a more educated decision about
my health.
The cool thing is that the individual trees
don't have to be great, if they give you decisions
that are just a bit better than random guessing,
using a lot of them will produce strong learning results.
If we go back to the analogy with doctors,
then if the individual doctors know just enough
not to kill the patient, a well-chosen committee
will be able to put together an accurate diagnosis
for the patient.
An even cooler, adaptive version of this technique
brings in new doctors to the committee according
to the deficiencies of the existing members.
One other huge advantage of boosted trees
over neural networks is that we actually see
why and how the computer arrives to a decision.
This is a remarkably simple method that leads
to results of very respectable accuracy. A
well-known software library called XGBoost
has been responsible for winning a staggering
amount of machine learning competitions in
Kaggle.
I'd like to take a second to thank you Fellow
Scholars for your amazing support on Patreon
and making Two Minute Papers possible. Creating
these episodes is a lot of hard work and your
support has been invaluable so far, thank
you so much!
We used to have three categories for supporters.
Undergrad students get access to a Patron-only
activity feed and get to know well in advance
the topics of the new episodes. PhD students
who are addicted to Two Minute Papers get
a chance to see every episode up to 24 hours
in advance. Talking about committees in this
episode, Full Professors form a Committee
to decide the order of the next few episodes.
And now, we introduce a new category, the
Nobel Laureate. Supporters in this category
can literally become a part of Two Minute
Papers and will be listed in the video description
box in the upcoming episodes. Plus all of
the above.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!